affects just disease specialist dr.
Anthony Fauci set to testify this
morning on Capitol Hill as a handful of
states bring back restrictions amid a
spike in infection rates with so many
states struggling to contain the rapidly
spreading disease Americans are urged to
wear masks and practice social
distancing the communication around you
are safer at home has helped save lives
and slow the spread remember
arm yourself with the mask it's your
best defense against this virus this is
real people like dying people are
getting sick people are going to the
hospital
people in ICU beds and people who are
asymptomatic or infecting their loved
ones so it just doesn't make sense and
quite frankly I have lost patience with
you on that regard so this is not a
political deal as we head into the
Independence Day weekend Casey Seigle is
live in Dallas for us this morning hey
Casey good morning Sandra good morning
to you yeah at least 16 states in fact
have now either paused or pulled back on
their reopening plans and Arizona is now
taking a much more aggressive approach
the governor in that state has now
ordered that bars are closed gyms
theaters water parks and inner tubing
businesses the latest statewide
directive went into effect last night
and it also caps gatherings of the
public at 50 and 10:00 at swimming pools
this is in response to both an increase
of new cases across the Grand Canyon
state but also a growing number of
hospitalizations 84% of Arizona's
inpatient beds are currently occupied 88
percent of ICU beds are full this is
real it's not going away anytime soon
and I would hate for any of you to see
what we are seeing on a daily basis so
stay safe please now in addition to a
growing list of florida beach closures
for the upcoming 4th of July holiday
weekend now you can add Los Angeles be
as well the County Board of Supervisors
voted to close all beaches piers beach
bike paths and access points all in an
effort to discourage large gatherings
meantime in Texas bars across the state
remain closed only open in a delivery or
carry out capacity if they meet certain
requirements that follows governor Greg
Abbott SIG's ecute of order last Friday
now in response about two dozen bar
owners and private citizens have filed a
lawsuit down in Travis County which is
Austin the suit calls the emergency
order unconstitutional and argues that
it suspends state law a power that only
the Texas Legislature holds not the
governor Abbott all along has said that
the bars were shut down because public
health data shows that they were a large
contributing factor in the spread of new
coronavirus cases especially among young
people
Sandra all right Casey Siegel live in
Dallas for us Casey thank you